do you believe every screenplay a
screenwriter writes
begins with their five favorite movies
um
no
and
they're probably better off
leaning into their favorite films to
inspire
what's next for them
um because our favorite scripts our
favorite films or shows depending what
we're
writing um
spoke to us in a deep way
um because let's i mean let's look at
this uh there's
tens of thousands of movies and shows
that we could have watched in our
lifetime lifetime you know one percent
of them or whatever we've actually seen
so thousands of people thousands of
movies and shows thousands of hours for
sure
if you get to the point where you're
writing a screenplay you've probably
seen
you know thousands of hours of content
so
of that let's say it's a thousand just
for hypothetical
which are the favorites and why are
those the favorites and then when you
get down to the specificity of
my favorite seven films
it's not gonna be like anybody else's
favorite seven on the planet so you're
talking about a very specific almost
code of what speaks to me and if you
take a look at that
there's connective tissue
in terms of theme or character arc or
genre
or just feel or tone or things and it
it's um
i found very instructive for me and for
writers that i mentor to
use that as the well i mean this is what
they could have picked anything right
they could have you know but the ones
that they saw and of the ones they saw
these are the ones that
sort of stirred their soul
so why would you not use that as a
resource to say
this is what i love most and now i'm
going to do my version of that
sure what if we're at a risk of of
putting too many let's say we're taking
from black swan or
we're taking that you know from the
opening of forrest gump or what you know
we're infusing too many things that have
already been done and people can spot
that and say
yeah you were that that's derivative
right we recognize that so the um
what we're always looking for is the
same but different
if for um if it's too much the same what
you're talking about then it feels too
derivative it's it's boring right if
it's too different
um
just it's too kind of weird it's too
idiosyncratic and it's like whatever
right
the stuff that's speaking to you
most deeply
has a beautiful balance of the same but
different someplace right in the middle
and when i create
my new version of the same but different
um
that's where the magic is i mean that's
where the really profound beauty is
if i
try to do that
and it's feeling derivative then i've
just leaned over to this pole too much
and i need to go okay i'm borrowing too
much for my favorite stuff how do i make
it more personal to me
what was going on in my life
that inspired me to like that movie what
is it that
you know so if you look at something
like star wars right none of us were
star fighters or
uh you know you know what do you call
him
he's a
fighter pilot or whatever it was um for
the rebellion
but like
the way like in episode four i'm talking
about the way that he um interacted with
his his families and uncle and the way
he kind of was like you know had to do
his chores and then he had this calling
to go on this adventure to face the uh
the empire um
we relate to that because
if we do if if we relate to that we're
living because we feel similar things in
our own sort of experience right so um
so if
episode four is on my list of favorite
movies
um you know you might take that it's
sci-fi from it you might take that it's
a hero's journey story you might take
that it's um
that he kind of had this mundane sort of
teenager type life and he was called for
some more sort of adventure there's
different things that you can take and
if i take x from it and i'm putting at
my screenplay and i'm getting a reaction
from people i respect who are going yeah
this feels like it's too close to star
wars then it's like okay that's
interesting how do i make it more
personal to me
you know because what i'm probably not
doing is going deep enough into what i
love about this that material
can i give this a try with some of my
favorite movies one of them being
forrest gump i mean i can speak to
forrest gump
i mean i saw it when it came out but
it's such a iconic film so i have some
thoughts on it um
if that were on um
uh
somebody's list of favorite movies you
know you might take away again
the thing is to look at the whole series
right um if you look at seven and if
let's say all of them are fairly similar
to forrest gump um
there's a there's a playfulness in that
there's an innocence it's sort of i mean
blake would call it the full triumphant
story um and so i would you know i would
look at that type of story i would look
at um the type of protagonist that was
sort of a special needs protagonist this
idea that life is nothing but a box of
chocolate so that's a thematic idea that
might speak to you
the setting it was like in the south
right in like georgia or some place or
alabama
so
i would take those elements and just
note them so it's a soft easy process
and then list your other six favorite
movies
and then you start looking about like
are there any other movies that are full
triumphant type movies from blake
snyder's professor or any other movies
that are sort of set in the south or any
other movies about um
characters that had special needs or any
other movies that have thematic idea of
sort of you know um
you know like like life is like a box of
chocolates or whatever that was or um
you know they talked about there was
sort of nostalgia stuff going on in
there too so you just take the pieces
and you start looking through it so um
and then you will see connective tissues
and you'll realize
i'm drawn to these things for really
deep reasons and when you come
with your new material you create your
new material from those deeper reasons
it's almost certainly going to be more
resonant more singular and you are
speaking to that as a creative authority
on what you love the most because those
are your favorite damn movies and you
can talk about them all day long as an
authority and so when you come from that
sort of
swagger and love and passion that's
exactly what hollywood is looking for
they're looking for you to be the
creative leader on your sensibility
because that's what we're doing when we
tell a story we're leading millions of
people on this journey from here to
there and we can't do it unless we're
comfortable and confident about what our
sensibility is so listing your favorites
and analyzing them is a way of sort of
making you already know what those are
but you're bringing it to a conscious
level and go yeah
i love these things and here's why i
love them and i can talk about them with
authority and from that authority
you put that on the page and then it
crackles in your own unique way and
speaks to other people
well russell crowe and i'm just
forgiving you the name that's where he's
the tobacco inside insider yeah yeah
fantastic yeah
so if that was on the same list as um
uh forrest gump so one connection i'm
seeing um with that
movie is you have
you know also kind of the both of them
have like this innocent kind of
flustered um main character i mean
well yeah you know tom hanks character
isn't flustered but he runs and
crazy doesn't stop running but the the
um the russell crowe character is
totally flustered and overwhelmed and
and so to me those are very significant
so if those were two of your favorites i
would say there's something about being
sort of in over your head
less um
you know sort of that fish out of water
thing but like
um but just sort of innocently kind of
stumbling into something and like it
being like a really big deal
so those to me are pretty significant
and
with insider there's also i mean that's
politically charged
it's socially social issue charged um
that one is grounded to michael mann um
perhaps at his best one of my favorites
from him and you got pacino who's um
this you know dynamic um sort of
crusader
uh and you have that beautiful scene in
the courtroom of um
so good that well that one actor i don't
know his name but he's in that courtroom
scene and he just he sticks to the
tobacco company he was just basically
like look you knew this was wrong you
did it anyway it's now gonna stop you
can't push you can't bully us anymore so
it's that that bullying thing so maybe
that's the theme in you so again those
are just two movies if you brought out
the other five you can start seeing some
really significant connective tissue
and then if you
you can almost see it like a lego set
right you're the lego set of your
favorite movies and then you take that
same lego set and then you create your
own new movie with those same legos and
maybe you add a few new ones but like
you are much more likely to to write
something that is so
connected to like your soul for the
reason that you came to the planet that
the thing that like
who else are we gonna go to about those
movies but you because they're your
favorite movies you can teach anybody
something about those movies because
your favorite so that's sort of the way
that i help people get aligned with
their superpower or where i do myself
for my own work if i get a little bit
kind of
confused about something or resistance
i'm like well how are they doing at my
favorite movies and i gotta look at that
and i learn and i go okay well they did
this and they did this and they did this
and i go well i'm doing this this and
this and then it's like okay well how do
i make those dots connect how do i
connect apples to apples with my
favorites
and and then once i do it for me
i give it to somebody else and i go are
they seeing it you know because if it's
just me if i'm a professional it can't
be just me it's got to be
eliciting the reaction the other people
too which is even more fun anyway
you